les dons ne baisse pas mais il
s'effondre voici le message alarmant
d'axel kahn président de la ligue contre
le cancer dans les colonnes du jdd ce
dimanche
l association de lutte contre le cancer
redoutent la disparition de certains de
ses comités départementaux comme
conséquence directe de la crise
sanitaire
bonsoir maurice brun en soit vous êtes
le président du comité des yvelines de
la ligue contre le cancer ce constat de
baisse des dons en faveur de
l'association dont parle
axel kahn est ce qu'il s'est observé
aussi au niveau local dans le
département des yvelines alors il faut
être honnête et dire que ce n'est pas
complètement le cas ce n'est pas
complètement comme non pas parce que
nous avons effectivement pu faire des
mesures mais tout simplement parce que
nous avons un énorme retard de courrier
qui nous a été livrée que en milieu de
semaine donc fin de semaine dernière et
que nous avons nous avons d'abord suite
au déconfinement réouvert nos locaux que
lundi dernier on payet remis le 11 bien
évidemment et que à la suite de ça nous
avons d'abord satisfait les besoins
immédiats d'endettement départ notamment
nos donateurs qui ont eu en général à
cette période ont tendance à perdre un
petit peu de l'horreur reçu fiscal qui
leur est nécessaire pour la prochaine
déclaration des impôts dont on a déjà eu
beaucoup de travail à régulariser un
centre d'affaires de ce genre et ne
l'ont pas encore pu dépouiller les
courriers que nous avons reçus pendant
cette période donc je ne pourrais pas
dire évidemment qu'il en soit ainsi mais
mais ils étaient vides entier que le le
centre des attentions de tous les
donateurs a été évidemment on ans et
deux mois et demi largement tournée vers
d'autres d'autres urgences et ça se
compte en tout à fait bien simplement
simplement c'est vrai que il faut
rappeler en premier c'est que la ligue
contre le cancer
effronté et subventionné en totalité par
les dons du public
nous recevons que 2 ou 3 % de
subventions d'état sur des projets
particuliers donc nous dépendons
entièrement de la gentillesse et de la
valeur de l'action nos bénévoles auprès
des auprès des donateurs
et deuxièmement si vous voulez le le
nous n'avons pas l'expérience de ce
genre de personne n'a l'expérience
d'ailleurs de ce genre de situation dont
les conséquences pardon vous les
connaîtrez dans l'est dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines dans une
dizaine de jours ressemblement est donc
la raison
oui alesis disons qu effectivement après
deux années trois années successives où
il ya eu là le changement de
dispositions concernant les les ailes et
l'impôt sur la fortune
ensuite il ya eu le gilet jaune l'a
ensuite tout ya maintenant se dégonfler
toutes étaient très déstabilisés ces
dernières années et c'est difficile pour
nous de faire gaffe allemands ni un
pronostic ni un bilan india est donc pas
possible encore de savoir s'il ya risque
ou pas pour le comité départemental
excellent thème parle de risque pour
plusieurs comités locaux départementaux
de la ligue contre le cancer en france
alors je pense quand même qu'on peut
s'en faire preuve de trop de d'audace
dire que ce ne sera pas le cas du comité
sont 18 parce que nous sommes prudents
devant les comités relativement bien
doté et deuxièmement nous avons un socle
de donateurs importants qui a évidemment
pas mal fondu depuis quelques années
mais qui reste qu'un important et puis
troisièmement nous avons immédiatement
dès le début du confinement ni en eau au
chômage partiel
la totalité nos salariés pour éviter
justement là bas le maximum de pression
pendant cette période de bulle de 10
l'action
un rappel pour ceux qui nous regardent
pourquoi ces dons sont ils primordiaux
pour la lutte contre le cancer à quoi
finalement certes il a financé ces dons
eh bien écoutez si vous voulez nous
dépenser en environ trois gâteaux si
j'ose dire
la plus grosse part va à l'aide aux
personnes malades
l'organisation de soins de support comme
on dit les visites dans les hôpitaux les
tout ce qu'on peut organiser pour faire
mieux supporter le cancer à ceux qui en
sont touchées
le deuxième gros poste c'est évidemment
la recherche qui effectivement elle est
est primordial c'est véritablement
l'investissement pour l'avenir et le
troisième poste et la prévention
donc si vous voulez
on a à la fois bien sûr de faire une
chute dans nos dépenses mais on a aussi
quelques dépenses en moins donc si vous
pouvez si cette balance entre les deux
qui devront nous permettre de dire quel
est l'état de la situation et vous
évoquez la recherche il serait
dommageable d'arrêter ses dons pour la
recherche la recherche contre le cancer
qui ne cesse de progresser
bien évidemment l'espoir de tous les
gens surtout ceux qui sont touchés par
le cancer
c'est bien évidemment les progrès de la
recherche médicale et cela c'est
absolument primordiale je le sais que
c'est absolument indispensable dans
l'esprit de nos donateurs et pour nous
c'est un investissement d'avenir sur
lequel on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
faire la passe une dernière question
maurice - est-ce que vous redoutez une
autre crise due aux effets secondaires
de cette crise sanitaire le fait aussi
que pendant cette période
des personnes ont moins bien fait
soigner d'autres maladies comme le
cancer ce que vous redoutez qui est une
conséquence à plus long terme
alors il est fait qu'un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux ont un petit peu écarté gip a
écarté volontairement mais n'ont pas
rendu les choses les plus faciles
concernant les personnes touchées par le
cancer qui ne peut-être n'ont pas pu
avoir accès lors chimio qui ont
peut-être eux-mêmes n'ont pas souhaité
aller voir leur médecin qui ne sortent
pas fait diagnostiquer pour lequel nous
n'avons pas fait les actions de
prévention
il y aura vraisemblablement des
retombées jeu c'est trop difficile à
dire mais c'est vrai qu effectivement en
tout état de cause s'il coronavirus a
engendré de près une trentaine de
milliers de décès ont en gros jusqu'à
présent c'est le cinquième de tous les
décès qui sont enregistrés chaque année
en france par le cancer merci morice
brand avoir est avec nous et merci bien
mais je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du comité des yvelines de la
ligue contre le cancer vous pouvez faire
un don à l'association via le lia le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran